day x has arrived
mount fuji japan's most famous volcano
is erupting for the first time in 300
years
it's raining ash lava and toxic gases
down on the world's largest city
what would it be like to witness this
epic eruption
how much ash would cover tokyo like a
dark gray blanket
and how could this lead to a rise in
china's economy
this is what if and here's what would
happen if mount fuji exploded tomorrow
mount fuji is located only 100
kilometers from tokyo where 37 million
people live
but this tall cone-shaped giant isn't
just any mountain
it's a stratovolcano
the last time mount fuji erupted was
over 300 years ago when it blew up back
in 1707.
it blanketed the city in ash
this volcano sits on top of the ring of
fire
the infamous and massive region of
volcanic activity stretching around the
pacific ocean
and when it comes to the likelihood of
mount fuji erupting again
the scientific consensus is clear
it could happen soon
and it could be huge
depending on where you were when mount
fuji pops
you could have a magnificent view of the
eruption
you'd see a massive plume of ash rising
from the peak and you'd spy red magma
pooling along its sides
if you live on the outskirts of the city
closest to mount fuji you could watch
the lava flow slowly head toward your
house
setting fires along the way
within just three hours you could be
among the first 100 000 people who need
to be evacuated to other parts of the
city
but even from a safer distance the
awesome view of the eruption
would be concerning
ash would start to rain down on tokyo
this would immediately suspend rail
service
that's because even a small amount of
debris on the tracks could set trains
off the rails
a layer of ash as thin as two
millimeters would make landing a plane
safely
nearly impossible
departing flights would be grounded
indefinitely
besides low visibility
volcanic ash particles could [ __ ]
necessary navigational equipment
and the heat of a plane's engine could
melt the ash
creating clumps inside it that could
cause it to fail mid-flight
you wouldn't be able to drive either
as the layer of ash grew to a thickness
of two and a half centimeters
roads would become unusable to cars with
two-wheel drive
the continuing pileup of accidents and
traffic jams would make the jobs of
emergency first responders increasingly
challenging
within 24 hours the city would
effectively shut down
cell phone coverage would be disrupted
and with just five centimeters of ash
thermal power plants would become
inoperable
many parts of the city would lose power
the ash would just keep falling for
hours days and possibly weeks
there could be 10 times more debris than
what fell after the tohoku earthquake
and tsunami in 2011.
but that ash wouldn't just be bad for
trains cars and electronics
it would be bad for you too
at first you'd experience a runny nose
wheezing and coughing
the contaminated air would make your
eyes red and itchy
if you inhaled too much you could
eventually develop silicosis
this condition could permanently scar
and impair your lungs
and not all districts of the city would
fare equally
winds would carry more ash to some areas
and less to others some districts could
be buried in an ash layer up to 30
centimeters thick
ordinary life would be nearly impossible
to maintain in the aftermath of this
eruption
so many forms of transportation affected
many local supply chains would be cut
off
tokyo would face shortages of food and
medical supplies
getting your usual clean water would
also prove challenging due to
contamination
not only that but the constant rain of
ash could form natural dams along rivers
putting some areas at risk of
flooding the eruption of mount fuji
would force nearly 1 million people to
be evacuated from their homes
globally it would disrupt supply chains
around the world since no ships would be
able to navigate tokyo bay
now japan is among the top five
exporters of goods around the world and
if mount fuji set japan's electronics
and automobile experts back
other countries could take their place
this could be huge for china and germany
who are also big exporters of
electronics worldwide
japan could suffer billions of dollars
in economic losses
but
things could always be worse
like the entire ring of fire could erupt
all at the same time
but
that's a story
for another
what if